[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
endlich mein mega leckeres rezept für
tiramisu
ein leckeres tiramisu rezept kommt ganz
ohne rohes ei aus und auch ohne alkohol
[Musik]
nun will ich euch aber nicht lange auf
die folter spannen und zeigt euch jetzt
zunächst einmal die zutaten wir
benötigen kalte schlagsahne
mascarpone doppel rahmen frischkäse
außerdem puderzucker sahne stammt mit
vanillezucker kalten kaffee könnte als
presto nehmen oder steigen kaffee sowie
ihr möchtet ein paar löffelbiskuits und
für die de cuba cacau
[Musik]
in einer küchenmaschine mit dem
schneebesen aufsatz gebe ich jetzt
zuallererst mascarpone und frischkäse
[Musik]
wer keine küchenmaschine da hat der kann
selbstverständlich auch das
handrührgerät verwenden und sobald dann
beide frisch käsesorten in der schüssel
sind geben wir puderzucker und
vanillezucker mit hinzu
[Musik]
jetzt wird das ganze ganz kurze
miteinander verrührt also wirklich nur
ein paar sekunden bis sich alles
einigermaßen verbunden hat
nun geben wer die kalte schlagsahne mit
hinzu und es ist ganz wichtig dass die
sahne kalt ist und frisch aus dem
kühlschrank kommt also nicht erst ein
paar minuten auf zimmertemperatur lag
nun wird das ganze gemeinsam mit der
sahne aufgeschlagen und an der stelle
geben wir auch unsere sonne stand mittel
hinzu und dann dauert es nicht lang und
die creme ist schön fest
[Musik]
nun habe ich
1200 gramm von den leckeren creme und
ein drittel davon also 400 gramm gebe
ich mir zurzeit in einen spritzbeutel
und den rest den bearbeite ich direkt
weiter ich nehme hier meine große
auflaufform die maße schreibe ich euch
nach unten in die infobox damit ihr
einen vergleich habt und stelle mir auch
man keinen kaffee und meine
löffelbiskuits bereit
[Musik]
nun konnten wir unsere löffelbiskuits in
den kaffee und zwar wirklich nur ein bis
allerhöchstens zwei sekunden lassen dass
kurz abtropfen und geben das dann in die
auflaufform und so machen wir nun weiter
bis der boden der auflaufform komplett
bedeckt ist
[Musik]
wer keinen kaffee mag der kann
selbstverständlich auch cacau machen und
die löffelbiskuits dann in kakao trinken
eine weitere variante wäre auch
orangensaft oder jeden sagt den ihr
gerne habt aber die klassische variante
ist selbstverständlich mit kaffee
[Musik]
nun gebe ich mir etwas mehr als die
hälfte der creme die in meiner schüssel
noch übrig ist auf die löffelbiskuits
ich gebe mir mehr als die hälfte darüber
denn wir haben uns ja gerade in dem
spritzbeutel noch ein wenig creme zur
seite gelegt und so ist das creme und
löffelbiskuits verhältnis einfach
perfekt und wir haben gleichmäßige
schichten
[Musik]
nachdem die creme einigermaßen glatt
gestrichen wurde geben wir die nächste
schicht löffelbiskuits darüber tun sie
auch wieder kurz in den kaffee und
gießen dann selbst verständlicherweise
auch etwas kaffee nach wenn das nicht
ganz ausreicht wichtig ist wirklich nur
dass der kaffee komplett ausgekühlt ist
denn ansonsten verträgt sich der warmen
kaffee nicht mit unserer creme
[Musik]
sobald auch die zweite löffelbiskuits
schicht auf der creme ist geben wir die
restliche creme aus der schüssel darüber
und streichen ist glatt das muss
allerdings nicht so schön bleibt sein
denn wir geben gleich noch mehr creme
darüber
[Musik]
damit nämlich auch die dekoration hübsch
aussieht werde ich die restliche creme
jetzt pünktchen weise darüber verteilen
und hier reicht es aus wenn ihr euren
spritzbeutel vorne einfach nur
abschneidet dann braucht ihr keine
spezielle thüle dafür und sobald ihr
dann fertig seid muss das ganze nur noch
kühlen
[Musik]
mindestens vier stunden lang gehört das
ganze jetzt in den kühlschrank dann wird
alles schön fest ich habe es in meinem
fall über nacht stehen lassen und am
nächsten tag ging es dann weiter und ich
habe das ganze einfach nur noch mit
bacau gestreut
[Musik]
den ba kakao gibt dir am besten auch
wirklich erst vor dem verzehr darüber
denn ansonsten kann das im kühlschrank
feucht werden und dann sieht er einfach
nicht mehr schön aus
[Musik]
und somit ist unser klassisches tiramisu
auch schon fertig für mich die
allerbeste und leckerste variante ich
bin mir sicher es gibt unzählige andere
varianten allerdings freue ich mich wenn
die meine dann mal ausprobiert um ihr
feedback da last
[Musik]
die löffelbiskuits sind super weich
geworden und die creme ist so schön
standfest schaut mal wie toll der
anschnitt aussieht ich bin super
gespannt auf euer feedback und natürlich
auf euren nach gemachten fotos zb auf
instagram mit dem hashtag igis kitchen
[Musik]
ansonsten bedanke ich mich fürs
einschalten und freue mich wenn ihr beim
nächsten mal dann auch wieder dabei sein
[Musik]